et nous avons croisé michel hinton
directeur du ciné lab dans les yvelines
bonjour bonjour vous êtes venus ici à
cannes pour les rencontres nationales de
la fca et l'association française du
cinéma d'art et d'essai qu'est-ce que
vous êtes venu faire concrètement ici
bas c'est un rendez vous important et je
dirais aussi important que les
projections du festival parce que là
d'abord on se retrouve entre entre
professionnels entre personnes qui ont
des salles entre exploitants et en plus
on voit des filles dans des conditions
confortables on voit des films qui sont
à la quinzaine à la semaine de la
critique dans des conditions très
confortables donc on voit là c'est un
rendez vous incontournable pour le
cinéma d'art et d'essai comment est-ce
qu'il se porte depuis la reprise de
crise sanitaire est ce que ça
c'est compliqué mais bon on va pas
arrêter de faire de la et c'est parce
que l'arrêt c'est un petit coup de mou
qu donc non mais c est qu il faut
continuer à passer des films de qualité
donc souvent voilà on travaille avec des
distributeurs indépendants et on va
continuer à soutenir justement c'est le
moment de soutenir encore plus les
petits distributeurs indépendants parmi
les films que vous avez vu cette année
est ce qu'il ya des films qui vous ont
marqués plus particulièrement oui alors
ça commence alors j'en ai pas vu
énormément j'ai vu le louis garrel
l'innocent hier énorme coup de coeur
voilà moi je suis pas j'ai je vois là
louis garrel je connais comme comédien
mais là je les ai découverts vraiment
comme
à metteur en scène qui a beaucoup
beaucoup de talent et je pense qu'on
reparlera de son film c'est un vrai coup
de coeur que j'ai eue pour la pole
innocent le festival ça fait plusieurs
années que vous venez est-ce qu'il a
changé depuis les débuts oui alors là il
faut remonter loin je suis venu pour
voir fois ici en 1984 donc
oui bah ça il ya beaucoup plus de monde
en plus moi j'ai eu la chance de
travailler dans le dans le réacteur au
festival de trois ans donc pas après ça
reste le ferai on est dans une bulle on
pense qu'au cinéma donc ça ça change pas
merci beaucoup michel hinton d'avoir été
avec nous et puis avec plaisir non c'est
un film de festival